the guy is selling things on the
internet only seven years ago telling
people that if you drink this secures
cancer who are you you got your
perspective be happy don't you want to
be happy
[Music]
does everyone see ya bye hello how's the
day going good awesome
great so in this part I love for you to
go around and give me some context on
who you are and what you do and then
we'll go back around and I will I you
know I think this is where you need to
go very selfish and specific obviously
it's unlikely that you're here without
some solid level of context of Who I am
in theories I think this is where we can
get very very very detailed so go very
very very cells I should the question
and see how many times we go around
[Music]
[Music]
makes me happy listen I listen you know
that's the doubling the biggest
vulnerability to my entire life is the
part that happens after I say it yeah
yeah you know like it makes me really
happy you're doing that they thought
what can we bring you we actually just
want to improve our results that's
that's one I and I you've got me so
pegged I want nothing but somebody but
it's it's really like it's the do you
know what it feels like to know like
your business life is better and
probably your life is better because you
listen to the right straight like it's
the best feeling yeah it just made so
much sense I don't have a question about
for any influencers
we are yeah and we're attracting some
pretty big people with like huge
followings
how thoughtful should you be about using
influencers meaning that if someone
could potentially be a little
controversial is that potentially
negative yeah sure could be what I was
saying to the crew and the crew all
nodded and I reinforced a big thesis of
mine the market won't be mad at you for
things you can't control but if you're
looking the other way because you care
about your business but you don't care
about that racial slur or that scam they
ran because you want the thing they will
not forgive you for that so it depends
on what you decide is controversial now
if you're if you're controversial
because his his training tactic is not
like and you believe in it that's
different do you see where I'm going so
if is a business controversial or is it
like cult-like on controversial
marketing in the marketing world a lot
of people think I'm completely full of
[ __ ] because they're wrong you know like
I really mean that
so like that you know is his technique
of training a dog or feeding a dog a
thing is that what's controversial but
you agree with it or is it like he
punched a woman and you're like [ __ ]
that got it yeah so to me we've got to
context it
[Music]
[Music]
nice parry
Mike how are you Monica so nice to meet
you Trevor it's a nice to meet you
just give me a few seconds thank you
guys today was a good day to just get
like some meetings in just to get back
on the field well we have a big office
there so just normal normal vaynermedia
stuff we had a four DS in LA
what can I answer what can I answer
let's let's bounce around we got plenty
of time good go ahead you're gonna
you're gonna appreciate my answer I have
a very good answer for you I would spend
zero seconds convincing people the reply
is like I respect and understand and
have empathy for why you think that
looking forward to conversating with you
in 22 years just don't spend any minutes
go focus on everybody who is already
considering it will really work for you
and I'd spend my life I've been able to
win selling the current because I go
into a meeting with
and in five minutes be like [ __ ] this is
not gonna work and turning an hour
meeting into a 30-minute meeting because
I cordially want to leak leave the
meeting because I already know I'm in a
place where it's no and I have no
emotion to getting them to yes because
history will prove that I was right and
so died on your sword
you know your patrons ma'am but wide
that's just that's super bandwagon right
no you better got you better have gone
to Michigan I heard brother there's a
ton of discipline and exactness on the
Arizona Cardinals in the whole world and
still wins you know it's a special skill
set I have to be very transparent about
this I think it's been crazy that he's
willing to bat Guerrero when Guerrero is
like clearly not a good human being I'm
so excited for the BALCO Barry Bonds
moment for Tom Brady I think Tom I
I generally this is like even on film I
genuinely think Tom's a good dude
I think he's made a humungous
vulnerability to his legacy in
associating so deeply with a guy who is
clearly not good crazy I'm like
fastening I'm like watching like in a
world where like I said earlier when I
see a lot of kinships with me and him
I'm like why in a world like back to
like when you have when you don't I'm
dying to know how the story plays out
because nothing makes sense with his
association with that guy he is in
business with a guy who is like back to
internet marketing and like all the [ __ ]
I care about like don't be that guy
that's what that guy is the guy is
selling things on the internet only
seven years ago telling people that if
you drink this secures cancer who are
you
and bringing to be I I know you do I
it's why I'm leaning into it cuz I can
tell you do to me in a world would he's
done everything right I can't wrap my
head around why I agree i I think that
like look I think Brady is suspended
because he's associating when I was such
a bad guy and so my intuition is he
doesn't get suspended but in two years
like he could uh like I think he's
putting himself in a place that he
doesn't need to be in like that's my
life at this point don't do anything
that makes you vulnerable to the fact
you've done everything right for 25
years why would I do that at this point
I might as well have done everything
wrong for the last 25 years to do one
singular deal it's back to Mentors makes
sense right and I can't wrap my head
around why in a world where I think he's
been brilliant and it's probably a good
dude based on everything I know which I
hate that part about him your hating
Jordans been great like anybody that
actually knows who he is he's a he's an
outrageously bad guy like in real life
whereas Brady's just not and this career
thing is really I've been like pumped
about I'm like why is he doing this is
amazing like I think I I do think all of
you in like six years when there's like
a big expose I'm gonna go [ __ ] like cuz
I just think he can't win that game bad
is bad and grey is bad I'm trying to
encourage people that are happy and are
good to share a little bit more of that
we're so quick to say [ __ ] you Delta and
Starbucks but we never say like nobody's
tweeting like how God Dirac will tweet
about the person complaining because
we're so on the same page about ice at
Starbucks a couple hours ago but it's
not our natural reaction to say oh great
job by the man in front of me who opened
the door for delay just not what we do
and I'm thinking a lot about that yeah
makes sense right yeah we don't talk
about good we talk about that and people
that are really unhappy talked a lot
about it my first speech ever in 2007
I get an email come to our internet
conference so I think it's internet and
marketing
what it was was internet marketing god
bless you so I get there I'll never
forget it I'm like what the [ __ ] am I
where am i I'm like is this like the
[ __ ] red light dish for like you know
like I was like I was freaked cuz I
didn't even know what existed and I
looked around the room and like what I
saw was people that buy lottery tickets
right and so I went up to the guy and I
was like and I had the cheque
I'll never forget it I was like I don't
want to speak and he was like super like
it was interesting I caught the guy at
the right time too he goes what do you
mean like we talked like at the AV
station before I was supposed to go on
and I'm like I'm not gonna do what that
guy just did I'm like that's do you
understand if I take the stage right now
I'm gonna spend an hour [ __ ] on
everybody who just spoke and breaking
this whole thing and I don't want to be
disrespectful to you I appreciate you
flying me out here you pay me a lot of
money I want to give you back the money
cuz I'm not gonna speak I need to leave
and the guy goes do it I was like dude
I'm serious because I do it and I went
up there and if I can destroy the four
speakers before I basically said they
were full of [ __ ] like why would you buy
$1000 DVD there's this new thing called
the internet it's 2007 I'm like this
Twitter thing's gonna be big YouTube's
real people in denying me back to like
the thing you saw that was 11 this was
at 7 same [ __ ] people are like it'd be
literally like me tomorrow going onstage
Emilio all right listen marce right
here's how you want to think about Mars
and everyone's gonna be like what the
[ __ ] is he doing that's literally what
it was like being a con artist or full
of [ __ ] is really good in the short term
the reason I leave money on the table is
because I want to statue
100%
you